The joe rogan experience cause you guys see the video of them,
uh,
with uh,
with of youtue and Jimmy Fallon on the opening night?
No,
I don't think so.
Oh my God,
listen is one of the most transformative moments of my life over the last year
was fallen asleep on the couch.
Um,
you know,
whatever I worked out it had something to eat and I was sitting on the couch and
a lot of times I watched like,
uh,
I watched like bow hunting shows or watch MMA fights.
I'm a fucking caveman.
If you came over and looked at my DVR,
you feel like,
what the fuck is going on here?
I just like what I like.
Okay.
I'm not judging myself,
but I fell asleep and I woke up and it was the premiere of the Jimmy Fallon a
first season,
first episode of it's night show.
And as I woke up,
youtue was singing the acapella version of ordinary love or acoustic version
rather of ordinary love.
And uh,
Jamie pull it,
pull it up.
Is that from the frozen sense to you too on,
Hahaha.
No,
listen,
it's a brilliant new song from you too,
but it's not just that it's brilliant.
It's one of those moments where,
um,
you're watching in Bano,
you're watching like a,
just a fucking brilliant artist.
Say what you want about that guy,
you know,
say what you want about his political ties and his charitable causes and his
sunglasses indoors at night set.
Which one about that guy?
That guy is a bad motherfucker and whatever it is out there that makes things
great,
whatever it is,
where you're watching pink singing while she's spiraling around over an audience
and,
and never losing tune and knowing that it's completely live or whether it's Bano
sitting on that fucking couch and youtube behind him playing and Jimmy Fallon is
sitting there and will Smith is sitting there and it's so undeniably brilliant
that I,
I woke up from a nap sitting on the couch to woke up just in time for them to be
joking around and then go into that song.
Like the universe wanted me to see this.
It's fucking perfect.
It's a perfect moment of entertainment.
It has perfect music.
It has a perfect response.
It has a perfect moment being the premiere of Jimmy Fallon's version of the
tonight show.
It has perfect being one of the greatest actors ever will Smith is sitting
there.
I mean a huge fucking movie star.
I mean people don't think he's a bad ass mother fucker.
I've never seen him play Muhammad Ali.
You know,
I mean if you don't think will is a bad motherfucker.
It's some weird jealousy thing.
I mean he's like one of those Tom Cruise type characters.
So look at this,
watch this.
This is all live too.
I never even paid
and it's rare that I hear a song and for the first time I get goosebumps.
Yeah,
we're all said and done.
This performance is going to go down there with the Beatles on the Ed Sullivan
show.
Same.
We'll take care of you,
fill that house and the tree.
Remember this moment
sitting there t shirt and gyms.
My mouth is wide open.
I was asleep.
And then all of a sudden,
purist version of what we love
about
this mother fucker is in this
room and here was his,
he,
he just has the routes to take in.
That's another level because now it's like this gets up and stands up.
Like it's going to be closer with them.
And you can see there enjoying it too.
Everything just kicks up to the next level
and the audience just starts going crazy.
They're going crazy.
He sees his three times.
That's crazy.
It was fucking beautiful.
And when they pull away,
the audience is standing up and they're all on their feed screening.
This is not a guy with a sign stand up,
stand up,
clap,
applaud.
Like if you go to those,
uh,
like if you go to the tonight shows shaping,
at least the old ones they used to have,
a guy would tell you when to applaud.
There's like signs would light up or a guy,
we're like,
hold up a sign.
It's crazy.
That was some beautiful shit.
Right?
That was amazing.
And I love the roots.
Got It.
God Damn.
I love them.
I loved I the band.
I love Jimmy Fallon,
but I loved that moment.
That moment is tell.
I'll never forget that the sit in and by myself,
gym shorts,
still sweaty,
like staring at the TV and it comes on and I'm just like,
God damn.
I just saw something.
I saw fucking shooting star.
I saw an asteroid hit,
I saw some freaky shit.
You know?
I mean that's crazy that an asteroid,
that's only happened once.
Asteroids hit too many times.
You know what I mean?
How many fucking,
how many times has there been a big hole slammed into in the earth because a
rock fell from the sky a lot.
How many times has youtube been on the Jimmy Fallon shy once you two was on the
Jimmy Fallon show?
One time ever and it was the first time.
There's only one first time ever in the whole universe that you two is going to
be on the Jimmy Fallon show.
That's crazy.
Unless you believe in true infinity and then that's the monkey wrench because
true infinity means if there is a you that the world is what you see.
Everything exists in the exact same form,
not only once but infinitely.
So not only are there so many possibilities in the concept of infinity,
infinity,
meaning infinite possibilities,
we can't even imagine what that means.
What that means is that everything that you've ever experienced,
everything that I've ever experienced you looking exactly like you,
you looking exactly like you,
you with the same creepy dude,
he tried to sneak you into the woods to see a fucking large mouth bass.
All of that exists in the exact same order and the exact same form in an
infinite number of times.
So that's how crazy infinity is.
Wrap your fucking head around that.
Like wait a second.
So somewhere out there there is,
it's not just one.
So right now,
right there,
not only that,
you two is playing,
you're not supposed to you.
It's like you too.
I say it like you shouldn't say it that way,
but youtube right now is probably playing an infinite amount of times all over
the universe and at the exact same moment how the exact same moment,
the exact same words are coming out of the exact same mouth.
That experience everything that has ever happened,
the idea of that never happening again on the other side of the world for sure.
The Not in the other side of the world,
but of the universe.
The idea of everything that has ever happened,
being unique in comparison to the creation of the world is so preposterous.
The idea that we're so fucking important because we are able to saying it,
capable of talking,
capable of explaining how important we are,
but the idea that we are any weirder than a black hole or a son.
I mean it's ridiculous.
So the idea of human civilization happening in the exact same order everywhere.
We'd be like,
how is that possible?
But how would it be possible for that?
It'd be other planets that's way crazier and this is a fucking shit ton of those
dude.
How would it be possible that there's water in space?
Oh,
there's a lot of it.
In fact,
that's where you've seen when you see a comment stupid,
you seen water flying off the back of that thing.
That's water.
That's a fucking earth sized chunk of water flying through space.
Holy Shit.
You know?
Yeah.
The whole thing is nuts.
It's not nuts that you don't exist.
Not just once,
but an infinite amount of times.
That's more likely than a star that's more likely than a black hole.
That's more likely than just the idea of people breathing air and staying alive
and fish sucking air out of water and some fucking weird contraption called
Gills.
That's nuts.
All of it's nuts.
The fact that it exists the same place in the same form all over the the
universe in an infinite amount of times and exactly the same order that seems
like likely you think are nuts.
It is.
That's why when you see a moment like you to on the Jimmy Fallon show singing
that song,
like you're witnessing a universal unique moment universal through everything to
the whole thing like that.
That feeling you get when you get goosebumps.
The whole universe got goosebumps for that.
It's interesting that you woke up for it.
It's like you're in tune with that kind of thing.
No,
I got lucky.
I drag a lot of coconut water,
tried to get some of that delicious sea two oh coconut water.
I probably had a p most likely,
but maybe not.
I mean,
I'm not convinced that reality is real.
I'm not convinced you guys were even here.
I don't know.
We're not,
what does youtube Internet stuff?
It's kind of a approximation of it,
isn't it?
Cause now we can,
we just watched it again and we were experiencing in a different way.
But that moment has been captured.
We can now repeat itself in our liquor controlled medium.
Right.
So it's maybe this is us piecing together all these things that you're talking
about.
I hope if you see it the first time you see it before I said anything about it
to you.
The last thing I want us to flavor that moment with some my own,
uh,
you know,
that's,
I think that was a,
just a tremendous performance.
If somebody sees it and you hear me talking about it,
shut it off and go watch the real thing.
Don't you know,
if somebody puts it on youtube,
it might as well be flavors by Joe.
Oh please.
Maybe salt would be better salt,
a little Kumon.
It's really good for you.
It's an anti inflammatory.
But you know,
do you guys feel those moments on stage and realize that you're tapping into
something unique when,
when that happens,
when you hit that that,
you know,
we were talking about when we were playing pool,
like sometimes you just hit this weird stride where everything's just fallen
into place and it feels like automatic and you know that there's that moment.
I'm sure it's,
it's gotta be very similar to the,
the moment like that in comedy with,
with your music,
there's gotta be moments where you guys are just flowing.
You know,
there was a Disney moment,
I don't want to make me feel uncomfortable,
but there was a moment where you were on stage and you were saying in,
and it was at the December 21st show,
the 2012 end of the world show and both Joey Diaz and Eddie Bravo came offstage
and they both at the same time go.
That's a bad ass bitch.
That's a bad ass.
Eddie Bravo.
That was a bad ass bitch.
Damn.
Those motherfuckers are talented in it.
He's like,
that's a bad ass bitch.
God Damn,
those guys are talented.
But it was that moment where you know you,
it was,
we had never done a show with a musical act before and a lot of my friends were
skeptical.
They were like,
what are you guys going to do?
Like how's that work together?
How's the wear?
So I go,
I think the music probably shouldn't be in the middle cause it would be like,
it would like interrupt the flow of the comedy.
But I think it would enhance the beginning of the comedy.
And I think,
you know,
so we do it this way.
And so when we,
when we did it and you guys got on stage,
it was the first time that Eddie had ever seen you guys live and uh,
you know,
he was like Holy Shit,
they're good.
Who's like the lyrics,
the fucking,
the music that,
the choices they made.
He just was just like shaking his head.
But I'll never forget that moment where they both walked offstage cause they
were both shaking there.
Cause you know,
Julian was going to go on stage next and do some standup.
We got so lucky to be involved with this.
Well we're lucky too.
We're all lucky.
We're lucky.
Shit,
I wouldn't be,
you know,
this is what the show would be completely uninteresting.
It was just me talking every week.
I need you guys.
I think you have a lot to say and it's very interesting.
People are hurt.
They've heard it already by now.
I've run out of Shit to say I repeat myself.
I don't even like listening to me anymore.
But we're,
we're all lucky for reals,
you know,
including people listening.
We're all in on this and some fucking weird way.
We're all in on this thing together.
It's just that,
uh,
folks like you and I,
and red ban and whoever's on the mic out there,
you're,
you're a part of the lightning rod.
You're part of the lightning rod that distributes all this shit.
But we're all in it together.
We don't even know what we're doing.
We don't even know why we're doing it.
We just start doing it.
And then somewhere along the line we realized we love it.
And the next thing you know,
he sang in songs or you're telling jokes or you're fucking making guitars,
whatever it is,
you know,
you find that thing
CP,
you find that weird,
weird thing out there in the world.
You know,
whatever it is.
And if you don't,
God damn,
keep looking,
keep looking of like,
go do some browsing myself up.
I don't even know if I'm honest.
No questions.
All literature.
It's all fiction.
It's coming from the universe.
Okay.